This is a ridiculous special bonus episode of the 99% invisible breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. A few months ago, Elliot had an idea. Roman, I just want to say you did an amazing job of condensing the last episode down really little. And I just want to say there should be a podcast called the 99% invisible power broker breakdown breakdown where it's just those sections
这是一期关于《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）的《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）拆解节目的特别加长版，我是罗曼·马尔斯。几个月前，埃利奥特有个想法。罗曼，我只想说你把上一集的内容浓缩得非常精炼。我觉得应该做一个叫《99%隐形：权力掮客拆解之拆解》的播客，专门收录那些回顾部分。
at the beginning, just the catch-up section. If you string those together, you could digest this whole book probably in like, I don't know, 15, 20 minutes when the series is over. So keep that in mind for the future for the Ultra-Bridge edition. Say you started the book, but you put it down for a while and you want to get back up to speed before you dive back in. Or you read the whole book, but you want a little refresher. For you, we present the 99% Invisible Power Broker Breakdown, Breakdown. It starts with a summary of the first five chapters way back in our second episode from February, 2024. So let's just start where we left off last time.
在开头，也就是那个回顾部分。如果你把它们串联起来，等整个系列结束时，你大概能在15到20分钟内消化整本书。所以未来可以考虑做一个“超级桥梁版”。假设你开始读这本书，但中途放下了一段时间，想在重新开始前快速跟上进度；或者你读完了全书，但想温习一下。为此，我们推出了《99%隐形：权力掮客拆解之拆解》。它从我们2024年2月第二集里对前五章的总结开始。那么，我们就从上次结束的地方开始吧。
At the end of chapter five, it's November, it's 1918, Robert Moses is about to turn 30. His career in public service has almost ended at this point. Like, he's complete failure. All of his different programs he has proposed have failed. But then he gets a call from his former boss's wife, Belle Moskowitz. Let's get to our recap. We're going to sort of pick up where we left off at the end of Chapter 10. It's 1924 and the New York State Legislature has just passed a bill written by Robert Moses giving him enormous like hidden power to appropriate and govern land to the new State Council of
第五章结束时，时间是1918年11月，罗伯特·摩西即将满30岁。此时他的公共服务生涯几乎已经终结。可以说，他彻底失败了。他提出的所有方案都落空了。但随后他接到了前老板妻子贝尔·莫斯科维茨的电话。让我们进入回顾。我们将从第十章结束的地方继续。时间是1924年，纽约州议会刚刚通过了罗伯特·摩西起草的一项法案，赋予他巨大的、近乎隐形的权力，让他可以为新的州公园委员会征用和管理土地，
Parks that is run by Robert Moses. He wants to build a string of parks connected by parkways on Long Island with his biggest dream being Jones Beach, which he envisions as the greatest bathing beach in the world. And the part that we're going to be talking about today is the use of power, where we find out where he gets things done. So when we left off last episode in a stunning turnabout, young idealist reformer Robert Moses has turned around and embraced corruption and dirty dealings to get things done. And this is the freight train that has been coming at us from page one. The heel turn is taking place.
而这个委员会由罗伯特·摩西掌管。他想在长岛修建一连串由公园大道连接的公园，他最大的梦想是琼斯海滩，他将其设想为世界上最棒的浴场。今天我们要讨论的部分是关于权力的运用，我们将了解他是如何达成目标的。所以，当我们上一集结束时，出现了一个惊人的转折：年轻的理想主义改革者罗伯特·摩西已经转而拥抱腐败和肮脏的交易来达成目的。这就是从第一页开始就向我们冲来的那列货运火车。他彻底黑化了。
And as a result, in three years with the backing of Governor Al Smith, he massively expanded the amount of public park space in New York State. He turned Jones Beach into the world's greatest weekend spot and built expressways leading to all that stuff. And he has become this absolute hero to New Yorkers. He's seen as this man who stands up to the wealthy and he can get stuff done. He creates parks for the people, even though we've seen that he will totally get in bed with these powerful people to make his projects possible and he will ruin some small-time farmers. He does some dastardly stuff, but the public doesn't see that. They just see these beautiful parks he's made. And this public idea
结果，在州长阿尔·史密斯的支持下，他在三年内大幅扩展了纽约州的公共公园空间。他把琼斯海滩变成了世界上最棒的周末度假胜地，并修建了通往这些地方的高速公路。他成了纽约人心目中的绝对英雄。他被视为一个敢于对抗富人、能办成大事的人。他为民众创造了公园，尽管我们已经看到，为了实现项目，他会完全与这些权贵同流合污，他会毁掉一些小农户。他做了一些卑劣的事，但公众看不到。他们只看到了他建造的这些美丽公园。而这种公众心目中
of Robert Moses and the private reality of how Moses gets things done are really diverging at this point. And through this, and the reason why he's able to get all this stuff done is he has the support of Al Smith. And unfortunately, in 1928, Al Smith runs for and loses the presidency. He cannot run for president and run for governor
的罗伯特·摩西，与摩西私下达成目的的现实，在这一点上产生了巨大的分歧。而他之所以能办成所有这些事，是因为他有阿尔·史密斯的支持。不幸的是，1928年，阿尔·史密斯竞选总统失败了。他不能同时竞选总统和州长，
at the same time. So he goes to the presidency, he reaches for that brass ring. He does not reach that brass ring at all. And Robert Moses is left trying to do the things he's trying to do. But there's a new governor in office and this is the man who Caro promises will be one of Moses's most powerful enemies. He is known as the feather duster. So when we last left the Power Broker, the Depression is dawning, Robert Moses keeps
所以他去竞选总统，试图摘取那枚金戒指。但他根本没摘到。罗伯特·摩西只能独自尝试继续他的计划。但新州长上任了，此人被卡罗预言将成为摩西最强大的敌人之一。他被称为“鸡毛掸子”。所以，当我们上次离开《权力掮客》时，大萧条即将来临，罗伯特·摩西继续
opening state park projects to great public acclaim. He's just a hero. Moses gets Governor Lehman and Mayor LaGuardia to give him total control over anything remotely park related in New York City and passes a new law where a state person and a city person can do all this stuff at once. He immediately refurbishes New York City's major parks. He's unveiled this massive plan for building expressways and bridges through and around the cities that people don't have to go through Manhattan to get to places on either side anymore.
开放州立公园项目，并获得了巨大的公众赞誉。他简直是个英雄。摩西让莱曼州长和拉瓜迪亚市长赋予了他对纽约市任何与公园相关事务的绝对控制权，并通过了一项新法律，允许州政府官员和市政府官员同时处理这些事务。他立即翻新了纽约市的主要公园。他公布了一项宏大的计划，在城市内部和周边修建高速公路和桥梁，这样人们就不必再穿过曼哈顿去往两侧的目的地了。
And the Triborough Bridge Authority has begun to actually start building the Triborough Bridge, which will become the centerpiece and provide all the funding for his empire as well. But there's a little bit going on here where his pettiness is starting to seep out to people who are his staunchest allies. So he destroys the Central Park Casino just because it was Jimmy Walker's playground and he just, out of spite, he just wants to level it
三区大桥管理局已经开始实际建造三区大桥，这将成为他帝国的核心，并为他的帝国提供所有资金。但这里发生了一点小插曲，他的小气开始向他最坚定的盟友显露。他摧毁了中央公园赌场，仅仅因为它曾是吉米·沃克的游乐场，他出于恶意，只想把它夷为平地，
instead of turning into something equally good or better, you know? And so, so that's where we are. So he's still like in that phase where he's getting a lot done. Most people are on his side, but that is about to take a turn right now with Chapter 21, The Candidate. When we last left the power broker, Robert Moses had run for governor. He had been such an unlikable, unpleasant candidate that he lost more than any major party candidate had ever lost before. And his reputation is tarnished. He's completely on his
而不是把它变成同样好甚至更好的东西，你懂吗？所以，这就是我们目前的情况。他仍处于那种办成很多事的阶段，大多数人站在他这边，但随着第21章《候选人》的到来，情况即将发生转变。当我们上次离开《权力掮客》时，罗伯特·摩西竞选了州长。他是一个如此令人讨厌、不讨喜的候选人，以至于他输掉的票数比以往任何主要政党候选人都多。他的名声扫地。他彻底
ass. But President Roosevelt, a unlikely savior in an attempt to remove him for good, has an order issued stating that New York City will get no more WPA money until it fires anyone holding both a city and a state office. This was an order written just to expel Moses. Moses leaks this to the press. He's able to frame this as the federal government trying to push around the people of New York City, and it is just what Moses needed to get his halo affixed back over his head.
跌入谷底。但罗斯福总统，这位不太可能的救星，为了彻底除掉他，下达了一项命令，规定纽约市在解雇任何同时担任市职和州职的人员之前，不得再获得任何公共事业振兴署（WPA）的资金。这项命令就是为了驱逐摩西而写的。摩西把这个消息泄露给了媒体。他成功地将其描述为联邦政府试图欺负纽约市民，这正是摩西所需要的，让他头上的光环重新闪耀。
And under Mayor LaGuardia, Moses perfects the system of providing physical achievements for politicians to run on while threatening to resign if he doesn't get his way. Although LaGuardia finds a way to take the piss out of him in this regard a little bit. Over the course of the last section, Moses is even more flagrant about ignoring orders and laws that get in his way, and he's even more ruthless about just destroying people who are trying to stop him from achieving his ends. But at the same time, he's beginning to get stretched pretty thin. He's doing all these jobs around the city.
在拉瓜迪亚市长手下，摩西完善了一套系统：为政客提供政绩以供竞选，同时威胁说如果他不顺心就辞职。尽管拉瓜迪亚在这一点上找到了一些嘲讽他的方法。在上一部分中，摩西在无视阻碍他的命令和法律方面更加明目张胆，在摧毁那些试图阻止他达成目的的人时也更加冷酷无情。但与此同时，他开始感到力不从心。他在城市各处同时处理着所有这些工作。
Most of them are not as accomplished or as thoughtful as like Jones Beach, and it is very clear that he's underserving New York City's poor and non-white population. And we'll see more of that ruthlessness and neglect in this episode. Because what's clear that Caro is getting to at the end of the last section was that this is not a man in love with his mission, a man in love with Parks. He's become a man who's just in love with power. The love of power. The rest of the 99% Invisible Power Broker Breakdown Breakdown when we come back. We're back with more of the Power Broker Breakdown Breakdown. So on the last episode, Robert Moses was showing what an amazing visionary he was, but also
其中大多数项目并不像琼斯海滩那样成功或深思熟虑，很明显，他忽视了纽约市的贫困人口和非白人人口。我们将在本集中看到更多这种冷酷和忽视。因为卡罗在上一部分结尾处明确指出，这并不是一个热爱自己使命、热爱公园的人。他已经变成了一个只热爱权力的人。对权力的热爱。休息一下，回来后继续《99%隐形：权力掮客拆解之拆解》。我们回来了，继续《权力掮客拆解之拆解》。所以上一集里，罗伯特·摩西展示了他是一位多么了不起的远见卓识者，但也
what a petty tyrant he could be. On one hand, he was brilliantly taken advantage of these like tax assessments and federal programs and archival research to complete the funding of this massive West Side Manhattan construction project, which is this amazing chapter and just like how he works down $109 million to something that the city can afford. On the other hand, he's destroying neighborhoods, these historic neighborhoods. He's destroying New York's last natural wilderness space without taking anyone else's need into account and harassing the club, the club, just because he can, because he thought that they were rude to him.
展示了他是一个多么小气的暴君。一方面，他巧妙地利用了税收评估、联邦项目和档案研究，完成了曼哈顿西区这个宏大建设项目的资金筹措，这是非常精彩的一章，讲述了他如何将1.09亿美元的预算压缩到城市能负担的程度。另一方面，他正在摧毁社区，那些历史悠久的社区。他正在摧毁纽约最后一片自然荒野空间，而不考虑任何人的需求，并骚扰俱乐部，仅仅因为他可以，因为他觉得他们对他无礼。
It's also becoming clear how much he is using race and class when it comes to his park projects. Like he's deliberately under-serving New York's poor people and people of color. And meanwhile, all these bridges and expressways that he's building that are meant to relieve New York's traffic problems are actually seeming to make traffic worse.
同样显而易见的是，他在公园项目中是如何利用种族和阶级问题的。他故意忽视纽约的穷人和有色人种。与此同时，他修建的所有这些旨在缓解纽约交通问题的桥梁和高速公路，似乎反而让交通变得更糟了。
And this is becoming this thing that is constant. It's almost a universal truth when it comes to building bridges and more roads and more lanes. But he cannot see this. This is his only solution, no matter what the outcome actually proves itself to be. And then we've also learned in this horrible chapter,
这已经成为一种常态。在修建桥梁、更多道路和更多车道时，这几乎是一个普遍真理。但他看不见这一点。无论结果如何，这都是他唯一的解决方案。然后我们还在这一章中了解到，这是一个糟糕的章节，
a good chapter, but a very sad chapter of Robert Moses' relationship with his own family, the decades he spent undermining the career and the success of his own brother and his disdain and sort of completely ignoring his sister and just completely undermining the vitality and the life force of Mary, his wife. So on the last blockbuster episode of the power broke breakdown, we covered Robert Moses literally busting blocks. You're not wrong. Roman is busting blocks full of people.
一个好章节，但非常悲伤的章节，讲述了罗伯特·摩西与他自己家庭的关系，他花费数十年时间破坏自己兄弟的职业生涯和成功，他对姐姐的蔑视和完全忽视，以及完全摧毁了他妻子玛丽的活力和生命力。所以，在上一集《权力掮客拆解》的重磅节目中，我们讲述了罗伯特·摩西实际上是在“拆毁街区”。你说得没错，罗曼，他是在拆毁挤满人的街区。
Robert Moses had successfully gained control of every ingress and egress to the Island of Manhattan. Like if you are in a car and you're trying to get to Manhattan or trying to leave Manhattan and all future river crossings, you have to pay some toll to Robert Moses. He controls everything. Robert Carr took us through Robert Moses' like turning the public authority into this mutant form that allows him to just have this vast amount of wealth to just keep him going and keep him making new things without having to rely
罗伯特·摩西成功控制了曼哈顿岛的所有进出口。如果你开车想去曼哈顿或离开曼哈顿，以及未来所有的河流通道，你都必须向罗伯特·摩西支付过路费。他控制了一切。罗伯特·卡罗带我们了解了罗伯特·摩西如何将公共当局变成这种变异形式，使他能够拥有巨额财富，让他能够持续运作并不断创造新事物，而不必依赖
on the fickle public or any politician's approval for anything. He controls so much of the money and Moses nearly succeeds in destroying Battery Park in downtown Manhattan with his plans to make it an on-ramp to this enormous bridge to Brooklyn, which the bridge eventually doesn't happen. But it takes the power of the president of the United States to stop him from doing this. But he takes this years-long revenge, like decade-long revenge of closing New York City's aquarium in place of Fort Clinton. And then he spends a decade trying to tear down the historic fort. Again, it just takes the federal government to stop him.
反复无常的公众或任何政客的批准。他控制了太多的资金，摩西差点通过他的计划摧毁曼哈顿市中心的炮台公园，他计划将其作为通往布鲁克林巨大桥梁的引道，虽然那座桥最终没建成。但需要美国总统的权力才能阻止他这样做。但他进行了长达数年的报复，比如长达十年的报复，关闭了纽约市的水族馆以取代克林顿堡。然后他花了十年时间试图拆除这座历史悠久的堡垒。同样，只有联邦政府才能阻止他。
And finally, this last little bit of Moses turning into the thing he hates by lending his support to the Tammany candidate, William O'Dwyer. And in exchange for lending that support, O'Dwyer gives him the post of coordinator of all construction. He's been the enemy of Tammany for his entire life and now he's this eager ally. He lends his name to support and sort of clean up the image of the Tammany candidate. And we again visit a old, retired, unwell former politician in the form of Mayor LaGuardia, and he is talking about how much he regrets giving Moses all of this power.
最后，摩西通过支持坦慕尼协会候选人威廉·奥德怀尔，变成了他所憎恨的那种人。作为支持的回报，奥德怀尔给了他所有建设协调员的职位。他一生都是坦慕尼协会的敌人，现在却成了热切的盟友。他用自己的名声来支持并美化坦慕尼候选人的形象。我们再次拜访了一位年迈、退休、身体不适的前政客——拉瓜迪亚市长，他谈到了他有多么后悔赋予摩西如此大的权力。
What LaGuardia is really nervous about is that now nobody could keep Moses in check. He thought he was the last bulwark stopping Moses from running roughshod all over the city of New York. So on the last episode of the 99% invisible breakdown of the power broker, we covered chapters 33 and 34, which detailed the ways in which Robert Moses spent the 1940s and 50s becoming the center of political corruption and honest graft in New York City construction world and his lust for power that has transformed them into this kind of political machine boss that he used to despise when
拉瓜迪亚真正担心的是，现在没有人能制约摩西了。他以为自己是阻止摩西在纽约市横行霸道的最后一道防线。所以，在上一集《99%隐形：权力掮客拆解》中，我们涵盖了第33章和第34章，详细介绍了罗伯特·摩西如何在40和50年代成为纽约市建筑界政治腐败和“诚实贪污”的中心，以及他对权力的渴望如何将他变成了那种他年轻时作为改革者所鄙视的政治机器老板。
he was a young reformer. And then, Caro does this delightful chapter on the three mayors that followed LaGuardia, which did not warrant their own chapters. It's hard to imagine a version of the book where Mayor M.B. gets a full chapter to himself as much as I love that section so much. So it's just a series of mayors that he dominated during this period of time. So on the last episode of the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker, Robert Caro took us on a lavish, luxurious trip to Jones Beach so we could see what it was like to
然后，卡罗写了这令人愉悦的一章，讲述了拉瓜迪亚之后的三位市长，他们不值得拥有自己的章节。很难想象这本书里M.B.市长能拥有完整的一章，尽管我非常喜欢那一部分。所以这只是他在此期间统治的一系列市长。所以，在上一集《99%隐形：权力掮客拆解》中，罗伯特·卡罗带我们进行了一次奢华、豪华的琼斯海滩之旅，让我们看看被罗伯特·摩西款待是什么感觉。
be wined and dined by Robert Moses. And then we watched him ram one mile of expressway through a Bronx neighborhood needlessly destroying it and bringing misery to the many lives Of its occupants in the process. It was a real roller coaster of an episode It was a real here's the good news here's the bad news about Robert Moses Truly and today we'll be covering chapters 39 through 41, that's pages 895 through 983 in my copy of the book. At this point in the story, Robert Moses is at the height of his power and control, but that doesn't mean it's always going to be that way. We're going to be finishing part six, the lust for power and beginning to move into part seven, the loss of power. We have arrived.
然后我们看着他毫无必要地将一英里长的高速公路强行穿过布朗克斯的一个社区，摧毁了它，并在此过程中给居民的生活带来了痛苦。那真是一集过山车般的节目，真是“关于罗伯特·摩西的好消息和坏消息”。今天我们将涵盖第39章到第41章，也就是我这本书里的第895页到第983页。在故事的这一点上，罗伯特·摩西处于权力和控制的巅峰，但这并不意味着情况会一直如此。我们将结束第六部分“对权力的渴望”，并开始进入第七部分“权力的丧失”。我们已经到达了。
into part seven, the loss of power. We have arrived. So last time on the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker, Robert Carroll went into incredible detail about how Robert Moses refused to include mass transit as part of his transportation plans and it doomed New York to a future choked with cars and traffic
进入第七部分“权力的丧失”。我们已经到达了。所以上次在《99%隐形：权力掮客拆解》中，罗伯特·卡罗非常详细地讲述了罗伯特·摩西如何拒绝将公共交通纳入他的交通计划，这注定了纽约未来将被汽车和交通拥堵所窒息，
and really explicit detail about how awful different railroads were. It was very vivid. But we also saw how an assortment of activists were starting to recognize the serious issues with how Moses was running his slum clearance programs and the public housing construction projects. So that was a little bit of a glimmer. There were rumors, rumors of rumors. So on the last Power Broker breakdown, we learned that Robert Moses tried to put a parking lot in the Tavern in the Green, on the Tavern in the Green,
并非常明确地详细说明了不同的铁路是多么糟糕。这非常生动。但我们也看到，各种活动家开始意识到摩西在经营贫民窟清理计划和公共住房建设项目方面存在严重问题。所以那是一丝曙光。有传言，传言的传言。所以，在上一集《权力掮客拆解》中，我们了解到罗伯特·摩西试图在绿茵酒馆（Tavern on the Green）建一个停车场，
in the Tavern on the Green, I'm not sure, one of those. Choose your own preposition. And ran against some moms who did not want it there. And it was kind of his first big New York newspaper defeat, which was a big deal, even though the crime itself was probably not as big a deal. And it sort of tarnished Moses' reputation for infallibility and incorruptibility. The New York papers finally got off their doves and started reporting on corruption in Moses' public housing projects.
在绿茵酒馆，我不确定，其中之一。选择你自己的介词。并与一些不希望它在那里的妈妈们发生了冲突。这算是他在纽约报纸上的第一次重大失败，这是一件大事，尽管罪行本身可能没那么严重。这在某种程度上玷污了摩西“不可战胜”和“廉洁”的名声。纽约的报纸终于不再沉默，开始报道摩西公共住房项目中的腐败问题。
One of Moses' aides, The Mustache, tries to pick a fight or does pick a fight with Joe Papp over allowing free Shakespeare in the park. This is another one of these just terrible fumbles that damages Moses' reputation as the champion of the people. The news media discovers some fairly sort of small ball scandals that are kind of unfair to Moses, as Caro sort of freely admits. But they do actually kind of stick to him for the first time. And it encourages him to drop housing as one of the things he covers
摩西的一名助手，“小胡子”，试图与乔·帕普挑起争端，或者说确实挑起了争端，因为他在公园里举办免费莎士比亚戏剧。这是又一个损害摩西作为“人民捍卫者”声誉的糟糕失误。新闻媒体发现了一些相当小的丑闻，正如卡罗坦率承认的那样，这对摩西来说有点不公平。但它们确实是第一次真正缠上了他。这促使他放弃了住房作为他负责的事务之一，
and resign his city jobs in order to become president of the 1964 World's Fair. And then, after he's lost those city jobs, or resigned from those city jobs, the new governor, Nelson Rockefeller, calls Moses' bluff. They have a little bit of a fight. Moses decides to pull his old trick, threatens to resign from all of his state appointments, and Rockefeller calls his bluff, and he accepts the resignation for his state jobs. And this is enormous self-own. That would be the true beginning of the end of Moses.
并辞去了他的城市职务，以便成为1964年世界博览会的主席。然后，在他失去这些城市职务或辞去这些城市职务后，新州长纳尔逊·洛克菲勒识破了摩西的虚张声势。他们发生了一点争执。摩西决定故技重施，威胁要辞去他所有的州政府职务，而洛克菲勒识破了他的虚张声势，接受了他辞去州政府职务的请求。这是一个巨大的自我毁灭。那将是摩西末日的真正开始。
And in the last section of the Power Broker Breakdown, Governor Nelson Rockefeller's plans to create a new Transp Authority leaves Robert Moses in the dust. And after 44 years, Robert Moses is out of a job. He still dreams of big plans, like the Fire Island Highway and new housing projects, but instead
在《权力掮客拆解》的最后一部分中，纳尔逊·洛克菲勒州长创建新交通管理局的计划让罗伯特·摩西被抛在了后面。44年后，罗伯特·摩西失业了。他仍然梦想着宏大的计划，比如火岛公路和新的住房项目，但取而代之的是，
he finds himself waving his pencil around in front of Robert Caro and giving speeches at various small events. Always asking, why weren't they grateful? The Power Broker Breakdown Breakdown was produced by Isabel Angel, edited by Comiti. Music by Swan Real. This episode was mixed by Martine Gonzalez. Original Power Broker episodes mixed by Dara Hirsch. Make sure you get your Power Broker Breakdown merch. There's a Robert Moses band t-shirt with all the dates of the episodes
他发现自己只能在罗伯特·卡罗面前挥舞着铅笔，在各种小型活动上发表演讲。总是问，为什么他们不感恩？《权力掮客拆解之拆解》由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔制作，科米蒂剪辑。音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。本集由马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。原版《权力掮客》剧集由达拉·赫什混音。确保你买到了《权力掮客拆解》的周边商品。有一件罗伯特·摩西乐队的T恤，背面印有所有剧集的日期
and the chapters on the back, so you never forget how much you read in 2024. We've got a great sturdy tote bag that our producer Isabel has been carrying her puppy around in. And don't worry, we are working on restocking those challenge coins. So keep an eye on the website. That's 99pi.org slash store. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu.
和章节，这样你就永远不会忘记你在2024年读了多少。我们有一个结实的托特包，我们的制作人伊莎贝尔一直用它装着她的小狗。别担心，我们正在努力补货那些挑战币。所以请留意网站。网址是99pi.org/store。《99%隐形》的执行制片人是凯西·图。
Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Berrupe, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Jacob Medina Gleason, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north
我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁佩、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区
in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find me on Blue Sky and Discord. You will link to the Discord site at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城的潘多拉大厦。你可以在Blue Sky和Discord上找到我。你可以在99pi.org找到Discord网站的链接。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。